possible cagnotte de 2 euros je lance
une pièce si ces piles vous gagnez la
gagnotte cissé face on va doubler la
mise et on recommence faisant un exemple
face double la mise au pas ça 4 euros
face double la mise on passe à 8 euros
pile
vous venez de gagner 8 euros question
combien êtes vous prêt à donner pour
pouvoir jouer à ce jeu bien sûr si vous
me donnez 2 euros comme vous êtes sûr de
gagner au moins deux euros à ce jeu vous
êtes sûrs d'être gagnant en me donnant 2
euros pour jouer à ce jeu mais
seriez-vous prêt à me donner 4 euros
pour jouer à ce jeu 8 euros 1000 euros
un million d'euros je vous invite à
mettre pause et à y réfléchir
allez y réfléchissez prenez le temps de
réflexion ce problème a été inventé par
nikolaus de bernoulli en 1713 et il est
aujourd'hui connu sous le nom de
paradoxe de saint pétersbourg mais si on
parle de paradoxe c'est parce qu'il ya
quelque chose de bizarre derrière tout
ça en effet la façon classique de
répondre à ce genre de questions et de
calculer la somme d'argent moyenne que
l'on gagne lorsque l'on participe à ce
jeu voyons les suites de lancer qui
peuvent survenir peut tomber directement
sur piles et gagné 2 euros la
probabilité est un pile et 1/2 donc avec
probité 1/2 on gagne 2 euros bossi d'en
faire un face pile et gagné 2,4 euros
et ça ça arrivera avec probabilité 1/2
pour le premier face et 1/2 pour le
second pile
autrement dit on a une probabilité un
quart de gagner 4 euros ensuite on peut
faire face face pile et gagné 8 euros et
ça ça arrivera avec probabilité 1/2 fois
en 2000 fois un demi qui est égale 1-1
en huitième puis on a une chance sur
cèze de gagner 16 euros et ainsi de
suite
en moyenne on va alors gagné 1,2 mille
fois de plus un 4 x 4 + 1 8e fois en 8 +
1 16e fois 16 et ainsi de suite ce qui
nous fait en plus en plus en plus près à
l'infini ça ça fait beaucoup ça fait
l'infini incroyable en jouant au jeu de
saint pétersbourg on gagne en moyenne
une quantité infinie d'argent je vous
l'avais dit que ça aurait l'air
paradoxal mais pour nicolaus de ce n'est
pas là le plus bizarre
le plus bizarre c'est que même sachant
ça n'a pas trop envie de dépenser des
millions pour pouvoir jouer à ce jeu et
oui parce que si vous me donnez des
millions d'euros pour pouvoir participer
à ce jeu il ya quand même une chance sur
deux pour que vous perdiez tous vos
millions d'euros pour ne récupérer que 2
euros
comment expliquer notre refus d'investir
des millions pour un gain espéré infinie
la réponse à cette question a été
brillamment fournis par daniel berd'huis
le frère de nicolas où ce taux est la
clé du raisonnement de daniel bernoulli
est ce que les économistes appellent
désormais l'utilité marginale
décroissante de l'argent en particulier
lorsque l'on passe de 0 à 1000 euros
c'est super cool ce sont tout de suite
plus riches mais si l'on passe de 1
million à un million et 1000 euros
on voit pas la différence mille euros ou
beaucoup plus de valeur d'utilité pour
le pauvre que pour le riche en
particulier daniel bernier décrivit
l'utilité de l'argent par une fonction
logarithmique ce qui veut dire que ce
n'est en gros que lorsqu'on on double
notre fortune que l'on gagne un point de
bonheur mais surtout quand on est
confronté à de l'incertitude comme dans
le jeu de saint pétersbourg ce qui va
nous intéresser ce n'est pas la somme
moyenne d'argent que l'on va gagner mais
l'utilité moyenne que l'on va en tirer
tel est le principe de la théorie dite
de l'utilité espérer mais ce ne sera que
de siècle plus tard que la théorie de
daniel bernoulli fut consolidée avec une
approche axiomatique 944 le
mathématicien john von neumann et
l'économiste oscar morgenstern publié un
livre révolutionnaire intitulé theory of
games and economic bur ce livre
introduit les fondements d'une toute
nouvelle théorie action baptisée pour
étudier les interactions humaines à
savoir la théorie des jeux ses
fondements reposent notamment sur les
axiomes 10 de vos neumann morgenstern
qui caractérise nos préférences
vis-à-vis du hasard et dès qu'elles
peuvent ensuite être déduit la théorie
de l'utilité espérait il y a quatre
actions de vos nomades morgenstern
le premier dit que tout individu a des
préférences complète c'est-à-dire que si
on a deux alternatives a été alors
l'individu en question préfèrent ou bien
à ab ou bien bea a ou bien il trouve que
a et b sont aussi bien l'un que l'autre
et quand je dis alternative là ça peut
être vraiment tout et n'importe quoi ça
peut typiquement être l'alternative où
je vais aller voler de l'argent mon
voisin en particulier les préférences
des individus pour les alternatives
inclut leurs valeurs éthiques et morales
comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 9 le
deuxième axe you may l'axiome de
transitivité et il dit que si un
individu préfère a à b et b à c alors
ils préfèrent a assez si je préfère le
chocolat à la vanille et si je préfère
la vanille et à la fraise alors je
préfère le chocolat à la fraise le
troisième axe au medac samedi de
continuité supposant qu'un individu
préfère a à b à c alors il existe une
probabilité paix tels que je peux
définir un jeu qui consiste à lancer une
pièce qui est une probabilité paix de
tomber sur piles et si ses fils
on donne l'alternative à à l'individu si
cette phase où donne alternative c'est à
l'individu
eh bien il existe une valeur de paix la
probabilité que la pièce tombe sur piles
quelques le jeu que je viens de proposer
est selon l'individu aussi bien que
l'alternative du milieu b dans le jargon
économique le jeu que je viens de vous
proposer est ce que l'on appelle une
loterie comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 5
et donc de façon grossière ce que nous
dit l'axiom de continuité c'est que si b
et entre a et c alors il est équivalent
à un certain mx2 à et de c'est le
quatrième axe hommes et l'axiom
d'indépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes dit on va supposer qu'un
individu va préférer à ap et on va
supposer qu'il n'ya une troisième
alternative
c'est alors je maintenant construire de
loterie la première loterie
lorsque ça tombe sur piles je donne à
l'individu
et si cette surface je donne c&a
deuxième loterie je vais donner
b si ça tombe sur piles et c'est si ça
tombe surface autrement dit les deux
loteries l2 à et l2 b ne vont différer
que si la pièce tombe sur piles
auquel cas l'individu a préféré l'issue
de l2 à à celui de l2 p et bien la
dépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes dit que lundi
lui préférera alors forcément elle
donnera à elle donnée à huy une petite
dernière chose en fait dans tout ce que
je viens de dire à b et c peuvent aussi
très bien être des loteries et bien le
théorème de vollmann morgenstern nous
dit que ces quatre actions sont vraies
si et seulement si il est possible de
représenter les préférences des
individus par des fonctions d'utilité
dont les individus cherchent à maximiser
la valeur moyenne
or chacun des axiomes de bono man
morgenstern semble clairement vrai du
coup veneman morgenstern justifie par la
la théorie de l'utilité espérer qui
deviendra un des fondements de la
théorie des jeux et de la théorie
économique moderne qui sont balèzes von
neumann morgenstern
sauf que non en 1953 le futur prix nobel
d'économie maurice allais réfuta
empiriquement les actions de vote de man
down under
considérons deux expériences dont chaque
expérience on vous laisse le choix entre
deux loteries et vous devez dire
laquelle vous préférez dans le premier
cas la loterie 1a est un gain assuré de
1 million d'euros
la loterie un b est une loterie avec une
probabilité 9% de gagner 5 millions 90 %
de gagner un million est important de ne
rien gagner que choisiriez-vous aaa ou
un bep dans la seconde expérience la
loterie de à est une probabilité de 90%
de ne rien gagner une probabilité de 10%
de gagner 1 millions la loterie 2b vous
donne 80 62 ne rien gagner et 9% de
gagner 5 millions et maintenant que
choisiriez-vous 2a ou 2b vous invite à
mettre vos réponses dans les
commentaires si vous avez préféré par
exemple 1 à 1 et 2 a vous invite à
écrire un un espace de à
allez je vous laisse cinq secondes pour
écrire ce commentaire
nous en résultats trouvés par maurice
allais allait constater que la majorité
des gens qui l'interviewent loi
répondirent un à deux baies et ça c'est
incohérent avec les actions devant
domaine morgenstern
en effet un à peu se réécrire un million
avec probabilité 90 % et 1 million avec
probabilité 10% tandis que 2 b peut se
réécrire 0 avec probabilité 90 % 0 avec
probabilité 1% et 5 millions avec
probabilité 9%
autrement dit ceci nous invite à
introduire 3a et 3b comme suit 3 ha est
un gain sur 2 1 millions alors que
troyes b va être nous probabilité de 90%
de gagner 5 millions et une probabilité
de 10% de gagner 0
on a alors un à est égal à 1 million
avec probabilité 90 % et 3 ha avec
probabilité 10% et 1b est égal à 1
million avec probité 90 % et 3 b avec
probabilité 10% tandis que deux à est
égal à zéro avec probabilité 90 % et 3
avec probabilité 10 % et enfin 2b est
égal à zéro avec probabilité 90 % et 3 b
avec probabilité 10%
sauf que par complétude on sait que soit
vous préférez 3a 3b
soit vous préférez 3b à 3 ha soit vous
êtes un différend entre les deux sauf
que si vous préférez 3a 3b par
indépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes vous devriez aussi préféré
1a et 1b et de à a2 b1 vert si vous
préférez 3 ba3 à part indépendance ou
alternatives non pertinentes
vous devriez préféré un ba1 a et b12 à
et enfin si vous trouvez que 3 et 3 b
sont aussi bien l'un que l'autre vous
devrez également trouvé un as et un b
ainsi que de zara et de b aussi bien les
uns que les autres en particulier les
actions de vannes oman morgenstern
prouve qu'il est impossible qu'un
individu préfère 1a 1b et préfèrent
également de ba2 à or allaient a montré
que certains individus avait de telles
préférences ces individus viole donc les
axiomes de vollmann morgenstern
étrangement ceux ci montrent surtout
qu'il est possible en principe de se
faire de l'argent sur le dos de tels
individus en effet supposons qu'un
individu préfère 3a 3b mais 2b a2a
on peut ainsi commencer par lui proposer
de a comme il préfère 2b a2a
il sera prêt à payer une petite somme
disons un centime pour remplacer deux à
part de b mais maintenant rappelons que
2b est égal à 90% de rien et 10% de 3b
on peut lui dire que si jamais on tombe
dans le cas de 10% de 3b alors contre
une petite somme disons un centime
on remplacera 3b par 3 à 1 comme
l'individu préfère 3 à à 3 b il
acceptera mais on retombe alors sur le
cas de la loterie 2a est égal à 90% rien
et 10% de à peu alors répété la démarche
intellectuelle et ainsi grappiller de
l'argent à l'individu centime par
centime
cette extorsion et ce qu'on appelle
l'astuce du livre de contes néerlandais
elle montre que parce que l'on n'est pas
tout à fait rationnel au sens des
axiomes de vaud nomades morgenstern un
banquier malveillant est compétent pour
à nous embrouiller dans divers
raisonnement de produits financiers et
ainsi nous extorquer de l'argent
alors il y aurait beaucoup d'autres
choses à dire sur notre relation à
l'argent et à l'incertitude et je ne
peux que vous recommander les ex en deux
vidéos de stupide economics et de son
étonnante à ces sujets mais ce qu'il
faut retenir de tout ça à mon sens ce
n'est pas le fait que les actions de
vollmann morgenstern et la théorie de
l'ue qui tu espérais sont faux oui je
sais que c'est faux ce qu'il faudrait
davantage retenir de cette vidéo c'est
que axiome de vollmann morgenstern et la
théorie de l'utilité l'espérer sont
avant tout utile en particulier ils sont
à la fois pas trop faux est suffisamment
simple pour que l'on puisse travailler
et faire des théories prédictive
à partir de cette théorie est pour qu'en
s'appuyant sur cette théorie on soit
néanmoins capable de prouver des
théorèmes utile pertinent comme par
exemple le théorème de guy barde la
nymphe on a parlé des électeurs
rationnellement irrationnelle et futur
one de chailly lui dit que ça fait
plaisir de se rendre compte que quand
même lorsqu'on doit prendre des
décisions d
mocratie bien souvent on n'est juste pas
assez informés et je pense que c'est
quelque chose que l'on met pas assez en
avant notamment du débat politique
classique entre amis ou à la télé on ne
met pas en avant le fait que bas en tant
que citoyen on est mal informé on
préfère systématiquement donner la
parole à ceux qui prétendent savoir
alors que bien souvent on parle graines
de questions notamment en économie où il
faudrait absolument mettre des réserves
sur tout ce que l'on dit parce que c'est
des sujets très très très très complexe
jean-paul fait la remarque que
malheureusement ma vidéo et n'atteindra
centre joue pas toute la population
française et que du coup la plupart de
la population restera sans doute
inconsciente de son ignorance et de son
irrationalité
et du coup la question qui verra passer
comment est-ce qu'on diffuse mieux ce
genre de message comment on fait pour
répandre la pensée critique
bien sûr c'est une question super
difficile aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
que le meilleur moyen de communication
des idées de zététique et de respecter
tic
si youtube c'est un peu triste à dire
mais les voies de communication
classiques notamment par exemple
l'éducation nationale sont quand même
bien incapable de répondre la pensée
critique notamment auprès des gens qui
ont l'âge d'aller voter puisque l'école
fini à 18 ans c'est pas facile il faut
beaucoup beaucoup de temps et j'ai envie
de dire que ça se travaille à tous les
échelons parce que moi je trouve
personnellement que même au niveau des
scientifiques ou de la recherche
scientifique et des gens dont on
pourrait penser qu'ils sont les
détenteurs de l'esprit critique
je trouve qu'il ya pas mal de travail
encore à faire notamment sur le
légalisme poétique n'est pas forcément
quelque chose dont beaucoup sont
conscients donc j'ai envie de dire que
la première étape c'est déjà sensibilisé
ceux qui sont les plus à même d'être
sensibilisés par ce genre de sujet et
qui ne le sont pas encore forcément
suffisamment aujourd'hui typiquement y
compris dans la sphère académique
il ya beaucoup d'hooliganisme
pro-démocratiques à dire que la
démocratie c'est la réponse à toutes les
tous nos problèmes est typiquement sur
ce genre de sujet il est très très
difficile d'avoir un raisonnement
critique parce que l'eau l'hygiène
politique en nous sur et
si c'est bien et on a du mal à avoir une
analyse très critique de la démocratie
et ça ça existe vraiment à tous les
niveaux pas juste la majorité du peuple
y compris dans des sphères dont on
pourrait penser qu'il y a plus d'esprit
critique bref c'est pas facile j'ai
envie de dire que l'une des meilleures
façons de faire c'est juste de partager
ce genre de vidéos lire partager mes
vidéos ça ça me fera plaisir moi mais
partagée aussi les vidéos que j'ai
partagé dans la vidéo précédente ce qui
est beaucoup de ce contenu très très
très intéressant qui gagnerait beaucoup
à être beau le plus connu à mon sens et
peut-être quelques plus de contenu de ce
genre on arrivera à propager davantage
l'esprit critique et éteindre autant que
possible l'hooliganisme politiques
notamment quand celui ci est
complètement injustifié une autre chose
que j'aimerais souligner qui a peut-être
pas suffisamment mis en avant par les et
éthicien à mon sens il faut pas juste
avoir un espèce de c'est comme ça qu'il
faut faire
je pense qu'il est très très très
important d'essayer de montrer qu'il ya
un vrai plaisir à avoir à développer son
esprit critique et en tant que
mathématicien je sais que le plaisir
c'est vraiment la différence entre un
mathématicien et un pas mathématicien
jean lui dire particulier je pense que
c'est pas forcément la meilleure
stratégie que d'essayer de se passer
pour des donneurs de leçons et qui est
beaucoup plus intéressant de d'aller
explorer certaine façon de penser de
voir à tiens ça c'est intéressant parce
que donc essayer de développer la
curiosité et le bonheur de découvrir des
choses notamment le bonheur de remettre
en cause ses propres intuitions pas
citer une réponse hubert pas clair et
ultra longue et c'est ce qui arrive
quand on pose des questions trop
difficile
bouly me demande si mon idée choquant
que j'ai utilisés pendant les
commentaires de l'épisode précédent
et l'idée sur lesquels les hyades vrai
faire tourner le monde non c'est pas ça
dix cas pas les hyades au jour
d'aujourd'hui les ja sont quand même pas
encore tout à fait au point en tout cas
ne sont pas du tout vers du monde pas du
tout pas du tout typiquement microsoft a
lancé son ia qui était un pote qui
parlait sur twitter qu'ils
interagissaient avec les gens sur
twitter et il est rapidement devenu
nazis troll en mode ultra fortune du
coup non les ja sont pas encore du tout
prête pour ce genre de nicholas me gêne
ce qu'ils nous demandent si les théories
démocratique prennent en compte les
hauts fonctionnaires alors ça dépend de
quel ce qu'on parle comme théorie
démocratique beaucoup il faut la
démocratie c'est un truc très très vague
si on parle des modèles de mesquita
mesquita c'est un modèle de la politique
régionale va prendre en compte toutes
les informations qu'ils pensent à être
pertinente en soutien dans son modèle
après parce que j'ai envie de dire c'est
que bien souvent quand on parle de
démocratie de façon théorique idéaliste
ou pour beaucoup de gens l'idéal de
démocratie c'est le peuple soit vraiment
aux commandes et qui puisse vraiment
décidés et ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait enlever les hauts
fonctionnaires qui ne font pas des
représentants du peuple
est ce que c'est vraiment souhaitable je
pense que ceux qui sont des hooligans
pro-démocratiques diront oui
et d'autres personnes dirais non alors
quand à émettre un avis sur sa santé que
c'est pas facile parce que moi j'ai pas
assez de données que je sais pas je sais
pas qu'est ce que serait la société sans
eux mais bon j'ai des connaissances qui
sont hauts fonctionnaires qui m'ont
l'air d'être des gens incroyablement
intelligent très compétent et
éthiquement bio qui quand même du mal à
imaginer que la france se porterait
mieux sans quoi c'est un avis pas assez
informés je peux pas pas de donner un
avis tranché
sinon vous êtes plusieurs à perdre un
petit peu espoir en l'humanité avec ma
série de vidéos est un petit peu triste
il ya pas mal d'aspects qui sont un
petit peu déprimant et ça ça me ramène
une remarque que j'avais fait il ya
quelques vidéos vous avez dit que c'est
un crabe à quel point la société se
porte bien quand vous savez que les
politiciens sont juste des gens
assoiffés par le pouvoir qui font tout
pour être resté au pouvoir
quand vous savez que les opinions qui se
propagent les mieux aujourd'hui ne sont
pas celles qui sont le plus à même pas
expliquer le monde qui nous entoure mais
celle que les gens éternue le plus
violemment et souvent en divisant les
uns les autres quand vous savez que avec
internet on a une ségrégation
idéologique croissante où les gens se
regroupent dans leurs fidèles bubbles
quand vous savez que toute l'économie
était également dirigé par des gens dont
l'objectif est surtout l'attrait de
rester au pouvoir et de faire un maximum
de profits et quand vous savez que les
citoyens qui votent et qui sont au
pouvoir sont des genres rationnellement
irrationnelle ignorants et mal informés
biaisé c'est fou à quel point la société
se porte bien et faire un petit peu mon
frileux mais quand je vois qu'il ya pas
mal de gens qui proposent des mesures
très radicales pour changer nos sociétés
j'ai peur que tous ces problèmes de
société ne soit pas pris en compte et
que les gens imaginent une société
idéalisé où tout fonctionne bien mais
sans prendre en compte qu'il faut que ça
soit robuste au fait que les électeurs
soient rationnellement irrationnel que
les politiciens veulent être
reste au pouvoir et tout ça bref c'est
dur de parler de politique sans avoir de
conviction et j'espère que vous avez
aimé cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va
parler de l' équilibre de nage qui est
le concept central de la théorie des
jeux si vous avez aimé cet épisode censé
appliquer à le commenter a partagé pense
à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les
futurs épisodes merci aussi pour leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois est-ce qu'ils agissent de
manière plus rationnelle que nous dans
cette expérience
la réponse est non quand on compare les
résultats des singes et des hommes
en fait on retrouve des résultats qui
sont proches tellement proches que l'on
ne pourrait pas différencier les singes
des hommes si on avait que leurs
résultats et c'est ça c'est la concavité
de cette courbe de satisfaction qui
explique pourquoi on préfère les liens
certains ou bien risqué même s'il serait
équivalent en moyenne si je vous donne
mille euros selon cette courbe votre
satisfaction serait 18
mais si je vous donne soit 2000 soit 0 a
une chance sur deux votre satisfaction
sera 24 ou 0 dont seulement 12 en
moyenne avec des courbes de satisfaction
concave la satisfaction moyenne est
toujours inférieur dans le choix risqué
[Musique]